today on the mat wall show the media has
been forced against its will to report
on the Vanderbilt Scandal but their
reporting has been uh less than honest
shall we say we have two especially
egregious examples today also as a
hurricane Bears down on Florida Amy
Klobuchar says that it could be stopped
by electing Democrats even though
Democrats are currently in charge and
hurricanes are still happening and an
elderly pro-life volunteers shot while
canvassing a neighborhood this is just a
few days after a craze leftist ran over
and killed someone because he was a
quote Republican extremist in our daily
cancellation Salon is having second
thoughts about the gender-neutral term
latinx all of that plus a major
announcement you don't want to miss
today on the Matt Walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
as you guys know I've recently updated
my style new set new blazer uh
controversial decision but we did it and
the best thing about my new style is
true classic tees true classic makes a
man look good and feel good no more boxy
fit or loose collars true true classic
fits a bit tighter in the chest and
sleeves but leaves room in the Torso for
that relaxed t-shirt feel and my
listeners can get 25 off true classic
tees with code Walsh at trueclassic.com
true Classics tease uh taper off towards
the bottom but they fit tighter around
the chest and shoulders all of their
styles are super soft and reasonably
priced for such high quality they're
more than just a t-shirt company true
classic has all the menswear Staples you
need polos workout shirts boxer briefs
you can um build your entire wardrobe
with them plus they have a pack Builder
on their website where you can custom
bundle their essential products and you
can save even more on top of that 25
discount in the process if you were like
me a few months back and in desperate
need of a new wardrobe check out
trueclassic.com use promo code walls to
get 25 off plus free shipping on
purchases over a hundred dollars that's
trueclassic.com promo code Walsh true
classic offers a 100 risk-free guarantee
with a 30-day return policy
trueclassic.com promo code Walsh true
classic when you look good you feel good
perhaps one of the most significant
things about our Vanderbilt expose is
that it has gotten a significant amount
of media coverage actually of course you
know usually the media prefers to Simply
ignore these sorts of inconvenient
things uh it's certainly been the case
for anything I've been involved in up
until now still to this day for example
my film what is a woman has not been
reviewed by a single mainstream media
publication but the Vanderbilt situation
has garnered attention from Outlets that
normally prefer to use the journalistic
strategy of closing your eyes covering
your ears and humming loudly to yourself
until the scary story goes away they
haven't quite done that here and that's
not because they've had a change of
heart mind you okay I'm not giving them
credit or accusing them of engaging in
Acts of actual journalism it's only
because they realize that the backlash
against the trans agenda and especially
against the transiting of kids
is gaining steam despite their best
efforts at deflection and they're soon
going to be in a position where they've
lost all control over it so they have no
choice but to engage now they're trying
to get out in front of it and shape the
narrative and the conversation in a way
that's convenient for them
now we have in other words dragged the
media Kicking and Screaming into a
conversation that it desperately does
not want to have
now as far as that goes there are two
articles uh both published yesterday one
in a national outlet and one in a local
that I think perfectly capture the
leftist media's approach to the
Vanderbilt Scandal and to this topic
overall in general and taken together
they show that the left is they're
backed into a corner here they're
intellectually out of ammo and firing
blanks it's no wonder they'd rather just
ignore all of this if they could so the
first article is from a publication
called inside higher education the
headline is Attack on Vanderbilt Clinic
has Ripple effects
it continues last Tuesday Matt Walsh a
conservative pundit and columnist for
the right wing right-wing website the
daily wire released what he called a
quote investigation into Vanderbilt's
clinic for transgender Health to his
over 1 million Twitter followers among
other things he asserted that vumc
established the clinic in 2018 because
gender affirming surgeries were quote
money makers that the center threatened
consequences for staff who declined to
provide gender affirming care and that
it tried to enforce compliance from
parents who might be hesitant to consent
to care for their minor children
Snippets of video are presented as
evidence for these claims
yes what I called an investigation well
I called it that because we
investigated Vanderbilt and we found out
certain things and then we presented
those things to the public
um I I do call that an investigation
because that's what the word means
but the few lines I just read
represent
the full extent of this article's
summary of the findings of my
investigation from there it launches
into a lengthy editorial disguised as an
objective news report slamming me for
quote intimidating doctors and quote
threatening access to life-saving care
and it of course makes the totally
unsubstantiated claim that quote gender
affirming care for minors is medically
necessary and as proof for this claim
they cite the leftist activist group The
the Trevor Project
okay they cite the Trevor Project as
evidence which I mean you might as well
cite Trevor Noah I don't know it's it's
there's no credibility whatsoever this
is an activist group but they're often
cited as uh sources for the claims that
the left makes on this subject the
article never mentions the fact that
Vanderbilt performs irreversible gender
surgeries on minors gives irreversible
hormone drugs to kids as young as 13
doesn't even mention that
and here's the most revealing thing
though
they could not find a single health care
provider at Vanderbilt who would defend
this practice on the record I mean
defend it to a publication that's
totally on their side they were trying
to find someone who would just say the
things that they want they were trying
to find a medical professional who would
say the things that they want them to
say
um and they couldn't do that in fact
they had trouble finding any doctors
anywhere who would actually publicly
defend the practice of irreversibly
mutilating and drugging kids
but they say that of course is my fault
too
reading again from the article says
whatever the ultimate goals of the
commentators and lawmakers scrutinizing
trans health clinics
the immediate impact of their work has
been to intimidate Professionals in the
field into Silence of the eight
specialists in transgender Health
contacted by inside higher ed for this
article only two agreed to speak on the
record all said they fervently believe
in their work but that the risks of
openly defending their practice have
become too great to make speaking out to
defend it worth the dangers of
harassment
right
so they refuse to defend their own
medical practices on the record because
they're intimidated
which is actually true
but they're intimidated uh in the same
way that cockroaches are intimidated
when you turn on the light they they are
intimidated because they prefer to
operate in darkness when no one is
looking they are intimidated by the
truth not by me not by threats they're
intimidated by the truth
they know they're being exposed
now they did find one person who would
um speak on the record though well two
they say and one is none other than
Michelle forsier who's the pediatrician
who appeared in what is a woman and who
famously if you watch that film you know
she would she was the one who would not
affirm that only female chickens lay
eggs she wouldn't affirm that she also
threatened to walk out of the room when
I asked her about the chemical
castration drugs that she prescribes to
children now forsier's defense of gen of
Vanderbilt's greed and profit-driven
Medical Care is that essentially
everyone does it she says quote anybody
who works in a hospital setting knows
that there are budgets there are looks
at costs and expenditures and more
resources go to programs that bring in
more money that's the economics of
Health Care any Cardiovascular Center
for instance looks at their surgical
income versus outpatient and surgery is
always going to make more money than
outpatient services none of that should
be shocking news
hmm
more resources go to programs that bring
in more money
these people just keep exposing
themselves and and you can tell why most
of them prefer to hide and stay silent
because every time they open their mouth
they accidentally say things that uh
proves exactly the point we're trying to
prove
and then the article has this this is my
favorite part it says forsier is
personally familiar with Walsh's brand
of misinformation and targeted
harassment
few years back she agreed to be
interviewed for his documentary what is
a woman whose Central thesis is that
transgender identity is a harmful and
unscientific fad forsier said she agreed
to the interview because she's
passionate about the issue and committed
advocate for transgender youth health
care but that she was greeted with
obstinacy and bad faith questions she's
been wary of doing any media interviews
including with inside higher ed ever
since
quote when you're targeted in terms of
hate crimes and victimization you're
careful where you go she said you're
careful who you talk to
now anyone can watch the film and see
that all of the obsidency and bad faith
was coming from the other side of the
issue but I am interested to find out
that she apparently considers
the interview that we did did to be a
hate crime
the interview was a hate crime is
apparently what you're saying
and we've gotten many
we haven't gotten many Critic reviews of
the film but I think that's probably the
only review you need maybe we put that
on the on the movie poster
now meanwhile on the local side a
leftist rag called the Nashville Scene
published an article from a woman named
Betsy Phillips and we'll have more on
Betsy Phillips in just a moment the
article is titled we are lucky as a
community to have a pediatric
transgender Clinic we have a place where
kids who are dealing with huge decisions
with far-reaching implications can speak
with medical professionals
that's how it starts that early gets
dumber from there Phillips claims that
kids who are dealing with huge decisions
should consult with the very people who
have an enormous Financial stake
in making sure that they transition as
early as possible
this is exactly why the profitability
point profitability point is so
important
because you don't have to be the most
observant person in the world to notice
that there's a conflict of interest here
okay you just need to have a moderately
functioning brain which is a bar too
high for Betsy Phillips to get over
apparently she continues
I want to write about the rights attack
on transgender kids and the people who
provide them medical assistance
but I have to be honest with you I'm
depressed about it it feels like for a
vast swath of us words have no meaning
so it doesn't matter which words I
arrange or how it's not going to matter
doctors and therapists are trying to
help trans kids are still going to be
called groomers and mutilators parents
who live every day with their distressed
kids and who are trying to find some way
for them to be in the world and Thrive
are called abusers it's not true and we
all could take the time to refute it but
the whole point of them doing this kind
of thing is to cause us to waste our
time doing so
well not the whole point I'm sure
right-wing activists and media
personalities like Matt Walsh and Tucker
Carlson uh their intention is to put
people in danger
so to be clear
the side that considers it a hate crime
when you ask them to define words
is now accusing us of treating words
like they have no meaning and aside that
that pushes millions of kids into brutal
surgeries that will destroy their bodies
forever is accusing us of putting people
in danger
continuing there there are some gems
like this it says it's okay to initially
be confused by the idea of transgender
people on the one hand once you um know
to to look for trans gender people you
see them throughout history
actually there is no historical
precedent at all for men who claim
actually literally to be women and vice
versa there has never been a society in
history that believes men can give birth
that's never existed until now but it's
not surprising to hear Betsy make a
historically illiterate claim like this
when you consider that this is also the
person who wrote The Following in the
same article now in response to our
objections to performing irreversible
surgeries on kids Betsy says this
this should go without saying but we let
kids make permanent life-altering
decisions that hurt them all the time
it's called football if you have Top
surgery and later regret it that's a
hell of a lot easier to repair than a
brain riddled with CTE
we see what happens to people with CTE
the memory loss the suicides the
violence against family members and we
all know it's caused by bashing your
head and how many of us spend our
weekends watching kids bash their heads
well what else do you need to know about
these people
she's saying body bodily mutilation is
akin to football
ignoring the fact that um well you have
to ignore a lot of facts to make this
argument but one of them that she's
annoying is that
traumatic injury in football
is not the point of the sport
okay that's what happens when the sport
goes wrong
whereas traumatic permanent injury to a
child through quote gender affirming
drugs and surgery is the whole point and
it's the only possible outcome
so the more accurate analogy is not to
football where injuries are a byproduct
a side effect
really the analogy would be simply to
just walking up to a kid and whacking
him in the head with a baseball bat
and then defending Yourself by claiming
that he wanted you to do it
and aside from all that here's here's
the the even bigger point
people like Betsy pretty clear from what
she said there
they don't want kids to play football
for exactly this reason
that it might result in permanent injury
in fact there are a lot of people these
days that say I don't want my kid
involved in football
why because it's going to hurt them and
uh and also because they are taking
risks that they don't fully understand
at this age
that seems to be Betsy's position
and yet she passionately advocates for
intentional permanent injuries to be
inflicted on kids in the name of gender
affirmation
these people cannot offer any argument
that doesn't defeat their own point
which is why they usually prefer to stay
silent
Betsy though did not stay silent and
there's a reason for that it isn't
disclosed anywhere in the article but
through a little bit of research
investigation you might say I discovered
that Betsy Works in marketing for
Vanderbilt's publishing imprint
so this is what the leftist media is
reduced to printing PR releases written
by Vanderbilt marketing execs and
pretending that it's an editorial from a
third party
well what else are they going to do
I mean they would publish full
compelling evidence-based defenses from
actual medical professionals but uh but
they can't because those people are all
in hiding because they're scared of me
and I believe that partially
I mean I believe that they're scared
but they're scared not because we're
jeopardizing their physical safety we
aren't
but because we're coming for their
bottom line
they're Prophets
and that we are
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well did you know that there are
currently over 2.4 million podcasts in
the world which is of course way too
many but the good news is that there's
also this podcast and it takes a team of
people to bring you this show which is
why this show is better than a lot of
those other podcasts
um needless to say you know we know this
here at the daily wire hiring the right
person is important and zip recruiter
makes it easy try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com wallship recruiter does
the work for your zip recruiter uses its
powerful technology to find and match
the right candidates with your job you
can easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply ZipRecruiter has a complete
Suite of tools that make it easy to
filter review and rate your candidates
four out of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day you can't argue
with results like that if you're a fan
of the show and you want to try
zippercruiter for free you need to
remember my special URL here it is it is
ziprecruiter.com Walsh that's
ziprecruiter.com Walsh wal lsh zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire
So speaking of that hate crime I
committed what is a woman now seems like
a great time to announce that I will be
touring college campuses across the
country this fall and screening the film
so I'm not just going to college
campuses to give speeches I will be
screening the actual film in its
entirety on college campuses around the
nation and we'll be doing a q a
afterwards and we can now now announce
the first six dates we've got uh three
dates that that we still that we'll be
announcing in the coming weeks we'll put
these up on the screen for you and if
you live anywhere around these areas
then you are invited to come to this
screening so on October 4th we'll be at
Catholic University we're starting at
Catholic University
um right in the heart of DC
and and you know if you don't know
anything about Catholic University you
might think that oh that's a that's a
friendly place to start you know
starting a little bit easy on Catholic
University they'll be very welcoming to
the this message
um that's unfortunately probably not the
case
uh
October 6 University of Illinois
um October 11th University of Central
Florida October 13th the University of
Houston
October 24th will be University of
Wisconsin-Madison and then October 27th
University of Alabama as I said those
are the first six states we've got three
more which this is a nine campus tour
and the three others will be
um announcing soon so
I've been telling you that we are waging
an all-out war on gender ideology and
this is the next step so we released the
film in June and it had the kind of
immediates
Major Impact that even exceeded my own
expectations to be honest with you and
now as you know we are moving to ban
gender mutilation in Tennessee and today
we're announcing uh that this fight will
be taken right into the breeding ground
for gender ideology which is the
University system
we do not anticipate that the film will
be necessarily welcomed on any of these
campuses
um especially especially not the
campuses we're going to announce soon
we've got some good ones coming up but
those are also good
uh but this is also where the film needs
to be shown
which is why I will go there personally
and uh show it to you
so the next step here is that if you
again if you live anywhere around
these campuses then or if you go to one
of these schools we need you to show up
in droves uh we know the left is going
to be there I mean we already we we have
it we've anticipated all of it they're
going to try to shut these things down
they're gonna have all kinds of dirty
tricks they're probably going to pull
they're trying to stop us from showing
this movie they don't want anyone to see
it
and uh but we have our supporters there
then I'm not worried about it okay I
want to
start with this
because there's a lot that we can learn
from this story though the real lessons
are not the lessons that the Washington
Post wants us to take from it but this
is a story from the Washington Post it's
a long story I'll read a little bit of
it
it says the day after uh Texas governor
Greg Abbott ordered the State's
Department of Family and protective
services to conduct a prompt and
thorough investigation of families with
transgender children
the first came up the first case came up
and Morgan Davis's name was on it Davis
was one of four investigators on a
Travis County unit tasked with reviewing
claims of child abuse usually he and his
colleagues took cases on a rotation
Davis was next in line that evening a
Wednesday in late February his
supervisor called and relayed the basic
facts a mandated reporter by law any
licensed professional who works directly
with children had turned in a family
outside of Austin because they'd allowed
their teenager to live as a girl under
the governor's order someone had to
investigate the family for child abuse
and uh that is correct you may remember
that when Texas uh wasn't uh a law that
was passed it was an order which came
down from from Governor Greg Abbott
saying that children who are being you
know
um who are being trans children who are
being indoctrinated by the trans agenda
this is child abuse and should be
investigated as such
and when that policy came down of course
I supported it
you know as uh and and I still do
because this obviously is child abuse
but there are some problems with that
approach
because if we're if we're saying well
let's investigate let's just investigate
we're not going to pass a law but
investigate this as child abuse
um well now it falls to Child Protective
Services the bureaucrats and CPS and now
you're you're relying on them you're
hoping that they will do the right thing
you're hoping that either they will
agree with you or that they can put
their own opinions to the side and do as
they're told
but that's not what happened in Texas as
we hear in this story
Davis's supervisor told him that she
knew work in the case might be difficult
nine months earlier Davis had come out
as a transgender man he was 52 born in a
generation when calling yourself tomboy
felt daring enough but after five
decades he decided he was finally ready
to live as himself
living as himself means living in an
identity that is the opposite of what of
who she really is on the phone the
supervisor said she was prepared to
offer Davis something she never had
before if you want to recuse yourself
she said you can
Davis had taken the investigator job
because he hoped to advocate for
children in a way he felt no one had
advocated for him when he was young and
I was and you know I'm reading this from
Washington Post but always there's an
asterisk every time I say he that's just
that's that's what they have written
here but that's not actually accurate
this is a sheep usually he believed in
the Department's mission of removing
children from abusive situations but if
he took this case he thought he'd be
carrying out what many in his Department
had been calling a political stunt
across the country Republican lawmakers
are pushing anti-trans legislation yada
yada
um and it continues Davis pulled in a
deep breath exhaled then told his boss
he'd do it if it's got to be someone he
said I want it to be me Davis already
had 25 cases of abuse and neglect on his
docket a load that current and former
CPS employees described the Washington
Post as unmanageable and then it goes on
uh it's like I said very lengthy article
so this is an actual this is someone who
identifies as trans
um only very recently like a few months
ago decided that she was trans
working
in child protective services
obviously I in every sense
opposed to Greg Abbott
is ideologically and personally invested
in affirming the trans agenda and now
this person has been tasked with going
and investigating these cases as child
abuse
and we're told in the article that she
did that and and she went and she looked
into it and just gave them the sign off
and said oh there's no abuse here
and now has gotten out of it and is not
investigating these cases anymore
see this is exactly the problem
you are
you know you're relying on a bureaucracy
that is against you
it's the same thing we encounter in all
these cities you know Governors can pass
laws they can criminalize something but
then what happens now you need you need
the actual district attorney to enforce
the law what if they don't do that
it's you know it's it's it's the problem
that people on the right the Republicans
and elected office face everywhere
um it's it's a major problem
it's not totally unmanageable I mean
there are ways around it
but this is what you're up against
because even if it seems like
Republicans are in control of the
government in your state or uh even on
you know if if Republicans if there is a
red wave and the next thing you know a
republican is elected president
and it seems like they control the
federal government well they don't
really because there's an entire
bureaucracy there is this Behemoth
blob-like monstrosity of a bureaucracy
underneath all of that
and the people within those those that
bureaucracy are not on the same page
so this is the challenge this is one of
the challenges that we're dealing with
here in Tennessee
okay if you want to stop
the mutilation of kids
how can you do it like you you can pass
a law
but then how do you do it in a certain
way where you're not uh beholden to
bureaucrats and other people who are you
know who can just choose not to enforce
it so that's a challenge is what there
are ways to do it but it's the challenge
okay a hurricane is poised to hit
Florida
um Amy Klobuchar says that there's a
solution for that as the as the
hurricane Bears down
she says well just vote Democrat we
wouldn't have these problems
you've got leaders in Congress uh like
um Senator Schumer and uh speaker Pelosi
as well as their Republicans that want
to work with them where we have been
able to step by step by step push these
bills through and so I think so many
times people counted us out but we want
to make clear we've got the backs of the
American people and while we have clear
disagreements we don't want if the
Republicans take charge a number of them
have been talking about an abortion ban
you guys know that you featured on the
show that's why we've got to win this
midterm we just did something about
climate change for the first time in
decades that's why we've got to win this
as that hurricane Bears down on Florida
we got a win in the midterms we
understand that but none of that has
stopped us from deciding we're going to
put our differences aside and get some
things done that is what that vote is
today in the rules committee where
you're going to see a strong bipartisan
support a very good hearing for changes
to the Electoral count Act
Democratic senator Amy Klobuchar thank
you for being on this morning
great to see you
yeah there's just uh there's not a lot
we can do for someone if they hear
something like that from Amy Klobuchar
and they buy it you know if you if you
buy that then I'm not sure there's much
we can do you're like a hopeless case
at least right now I hope not
permanently but uh there are a lot of
there's a lot of work you need to do
within yourself
if you hear that and and you think oh
yeah well just vote Democrat and uh and
there'll be there'll be no no hurricanes
first of all
just to State the obvious well there are
a few obvious things we have to State
one of them is that
we have Democrats who control Congress
we have a democrat in the white house
right now
and there are still hurricanes so turns
out that voting Democrat doesn't stop
hurricanes from happening
is that their fault
I mean maybe maybe this is what we need
to start doing we can't because then
we're adopting the left's premise and
we're agreeing with it so we can't
really but it does seem sort of tempting
to just uh to play their game and say
okay well hurricanes are political
events now and uh they're the result of
bad policy
so if there's you know a hurricane hits
Florida and God forbid lots of people
dies a lot of damage
Democrats fault you should have stopped
that you didn't this is all on you
but even that we can't really say of
course because the other obvious thing
we need to say is that hurricanes
um have been happening on this planet
basically since the planet was formed
or at least since it's had an atmosphere
certainly certainly way before there
weren't any political parties in this
country or there was a country at all
or before the continent even existed in
its current shape
there were hurricanes
did you know they're actually there are
hurricanes on other planets that happen
there's been a massive hurricane
happening on we have a little bit more
in Jupiter a little bit later in the
five headlines
um
but there's been a hurricane on Jupiter
for like hundreds of years massive
hurricane
A hurricane's so big that you could fit
multiple Earths inside of it
I guess it's because they don't have you
know they don't have Amy Klobuchar on
Jupiter to pass legislation to put a
stop to that
oh it says an elderly pro-life volunteer
in Michigan was shot in the shoulder
while canvassing a neighborhood to
discuss an abortion ballot proposal
according to right to life of Michigan
the victim said that she was shot in the
back slash shoulder while leaving a
residence during a heated conversation
at the man who shot her was not a part
of her conversation
this according to the pro-life Group
which wrote in a press release on
Saturday the unidentified woman is 83
years old
according to the police
um though the right to life Michigan
identified as 80 40 years old either way
she's in her 80s she's an elderly woman
pro-lifer she's canvassing the
neighborhood and then she was shot the
woman was campusing a neighborhood in
Lake Odessa to discuss the state's
proposal on the vote on proposal three
which would protect abortion access in
the state state will vote on The
Proposal on November 8th on the general
election ballot Okay so
let's just review here what we've seen
so we've got
a
elderly pro-life woman who was shot in
the back while canvassing a neighborhood
um there was also the case a few just a
few days ago of a republican who was run
over and killed
by a guy who admits he did it because he
thought that the kid was a republican
extremist was were his words
and in the midst of all sandwiched in
between those two events we had the FBI
rolling up with 15 cars and 30 agents
dragging a pro-life activist out of his
house at gunpoint
despite the fact that he committed no
crimes whatsoever
this is a
their waging of all at War on us at this
point is what's happening
just a matter of like when do we decide
to pay attention and uh and acknowledge
that
and while this is happening it's they
accuse us right they're sending FBI 30
FBI agents to a pro-lifer's home again
did not commit any crime
the case was dropped in court because no
crime was committed
and Biden's doj picks up the case and
says yeah just send some send some ages
to his house just to scare him
and we looked we have to assume that was
the the reason there was no there's no
crime you can't charge them with
anything
so it's just intimidation tactic
so sending the 30 agents to a
pro-liver's home and they're doing that
while accusing the right of being
fascists
and meanwhile you have pro-lifers and
Republicans getting mowed down and shot
while they're walking down the street
and they accuse us of being violent
extremists
well the Atlanta Braves visited uh the
White House yesterday
prompting this question from the media
let's listen to this
president hosting the Atlanta Braves
today wondering if you or the president
has any thoughts about some of the
controversial about the team name the
Braves name the so-called Tomahawk
machine
so we we believe that it's important
um to have this conversation uh you know
and uh and Native American and
Indigenous voices they should be at the
center of this conversation that is
something that the president believes as
something that this Administration
believes and he is consistently
emphasized that all people deserve to be
treated with dignity and respect you
hear that often from this President the
same is true here and we should listen
to Native American and Indigenous people
who are the most impacted by this
yeah it's actually not important at all
to be having this conversation can I
just clarify like of in fact evolve if I
were to make a list of all of the
conversations that it's important for us
to have
um I think a conversation about the
Atlanta Braves and whether the name is
offensive that's gonna I don't know
maybe make it into the top
20 million very close to the bottom
uh although I I would be interested to
hear her elaborate
no it's it's not an important
conversation it's not one that certainly
the White House needs to be having but
uh
if we're going to have it please
elaborate exactly please explain
how it is offensive exactly
to have a team named after an Indian
tribe
I mean this is this is the sort of thing
that's just like it's taken as as
self-evident doesn't even need to be
explained
well teams named after an end Drive of
course of course it's offensive why is
it offensive
that's that's the thing I've never
understood why is it not
um honoring
so that's what you do with a team name
you don't you don't you don't choose a
team name uh based on you don't you
don't name your team after something or
after a group of people after anything
that you find to be pathetic or shameful
or embarrassing
that's not what you do you choose the
team name because you think it's uh you
you it's it's formidable
uh courageous
right tough strong I mean these are all
especially for for uh well this is not
football team it's a baseball team but I
guess it doesn't really quite it doesn't
quite apply to baseball players as it
does to football but either way that's
why you choose a team
because that's the association you're
trying to make so explain to me exactly
uh how that's insulting that's what I
don't understand
but we've just accepted that it is and
then the result is now we're taking it's
not just with team names either
what we've been told is that you got to
take especially Native American
references
wherever you can find them whether it's
a baseball team uh or it's uh you know a
Native American woman on the
box of a box of butter and take those
things away
remove all of these references to Native
American culture all these
acknowledgments of Native American
culture remove them and then what that's
progress
the more we erase Native American
culture from American culture we that's
that's now a sign of progress
not sure I quite understand that
uh
Ben Shapiro was trending two nights ago
because of this as Yahoo reports
right-wing commentator Ben Shapiro was
the subject of much mockery this weekend
after he claimed the U.S military is
suffering because the country has
abandoned traditional masculinity
in a clip posted on Twitter by Ron
philipkowski the daily wire founder
suggested that Wars are best fought by
what he described as typically very
patriotic very male people according
Shapiro was never served in the military
men are supposed to protect defend and
be strong
shocking statement many people didn't
agree with Shapiro at all including
people who had actually had a military
background such as Tom Nichols a retired
professor at the U.S naval war college
and staff writer for the Atlantic
Nichols not only said Shapiro didn't
have a clue what he was talking about
but also pointed out that Russia is
having a hard time against Ukraine
despite being the opposite of what Ted
Cruz referred to as America's welcome
masculated military others piled on
Shapiro including representative Adam
kinzinger a former Air Force second
Lieutenant well if anyone is an expert
on masculinity it's Adam kinsinger of
course let's actually let's watch the
offensive clip from Ben let's let's hear
it
guess who tends to fight Wars the people
who tend to fight Wars are typically
very patriotic very male people
man I'm sorry to break at you but this
has been the truth about military
Warfare for literally all of human
history
and the institution of traditional
masculinity has been core to that idea
but we're a society that doesn't believe
in traditional masculinity traditional
masculinity is an opponent because
traditional masculinity requires roles
it says that men are supposed to protect
and are supposed to defend and are
supposed to be strong men are supposed
to be fathers and husbands
these are apparently very bad things now
you're not supposed to say these things
hilarious I mean what an idiot Ben is
for saying this
obviously true thing and he was he was
trending from what I could see he was
trending on Twitter for I'd say two days
because of what you just heard there
a statement that
uh now it's one thing it's a Twitter
finds it shocking
uh the media finds it shocking the left
finds it shocking but you take that clip
you know on your phone and you walk up
to just any normal person on the street
and you show them that and get their
reaction
what you're going to get from 90 of them
is like yeah of course
that you want you want the military to
be masculine and tough and strong and
that's what you want the military to be
like as opposed to what what else would
you want the military to be
emasculated do you want a feminine
military is that what you want
uh yet again a a completely obvious
self-evident statement that is treated
as shocking by the left and here's
another important point about this
because this is something that Ben is is
pointing to here and what he just said
that yeah we want for for our for our
sake for the country's sake we want our
military to be masculine tough strong we
want them to just be badass dudes who
are good at killing bad guys like that's
what you want
and that used to be
not just the emphasis in the military
but the only Point like that's that's
that was you're recruiting people you're
recruiting badass dudes who want to kill
bad guys are going to be good at doing
it that's it
um there aren't very many other there
are other some other qualifications but
that's the Central Point that's what you
need
so we want that for our own sake so that
we can be safe as a country and uh and
we have a military like that defending
us
but then also we want that for the men
in this country especially the young men
because
no matter how we try to condition them
you know young men have this kind of
masculine energy they have their they
they have aggression
right
young men are much more physically
aggressive than young women
and
we can do one of two things with that
we can scold young men
and tell them that it's very bad to be
like that you shouldn't be like it's
toxic
it's very bad
try to get them to suppress it
so you can try to do that
and we see how well that works
it doesn't work at all
I mean the more that we scold and yell
at and tried to emasculate men has it
has it actually succeeded
in curbing violence or anything else no
so instead of that strategy what you can
do is try to harness it
and you could say to young men okay
you've got all this aggression you've
got all this physical energy
um here's here's a way to use it okay
you can use it in a noble way
for example by serving in the military
we could say the young man like the
military is made for you you guys are
made for each other
um
so you could try to suppress it
as a society
masculine energy and and aggression you
can try to suppress it or you could try
to harness it
you could tell you could tell men where
to target it what to do with it
it's not just the military like not
every man needs to join the military but
this is also where Sports have come into
play
this is why football is is good for for
uh young men too even with the the risk
of injury
still a good thing
because it gives them an outlet for that
energy for that uh for that aggression
before we get to the uh
comment section I wanted to also mention
this it's from The Washington Post
starting this weekend Sky gazers will
see a rare view of Jupiter as it appears
its biggest and brightest in decades
Jupiter will be one of the most
brilliant natural objects if not the
most in the night sky on Sunday Jupiter
will reach its closest distance to Earth
in 59 years at around
367 million miles on Monday the gas
giant will reach opposition meaning it
will appear opposite the sun to those on
Earth Jupiter will rise in the east
while the sun sets in the west this was
last night if you uh if unfortunately
already missed it so this will be last
night was the brightest the Jupiter will
appear has appeared in 59 years and it
won't appear that uh bright in the sky
again until about the year 2139
we we went out a couple of times last
night to check out Jupiter which was
just spectacular uh I mean this is the
largest planet in the solar system twice
the size it's twice the size of every
other planet in the solar system
combined
it's the most ancient too in fact our
planet was was probably formed
from the pieces of planets that Jupiter
destroyed as it was hurtling through the
early solar system uh it's got that big
red spot I already mentioned which is a
Hurricane's been raging for like 400
years it's so big you could fit Two
Earths inside it uh Amy Klobuchar could
pass legislation to stop it and she
hasn't yet
and then it's got 67 moons one of which
is Europa which is the the likeliest
candidate for extraterrestrial life in
the solar system this is fascinating
stuff
so if you haven't gotten outside to see
Jupiter you need to do it
my sweet babies
I beseech you
let's get to the comment section
Karina says before taking your child to
a drag show ask yourself would I take my
child to a strip club your answer for
both should be no
yes it is a very similar thing the only
problem with that argument Karina is
that
I'm not sure that the average parent who
takes their child to a drag show
wouldn't also take them to a strip club
you know if if as a parent it's not
immediately obvious to you why a drag
show is inappropriate for your child
then I'm not sure it would be obvious
why a strip club is inappropriate
Governor says Matt children especially
younger children recognize evil out of
the box that little girl and any of the
other children who are trying to hide or
avoid those badly wired pseudo-male
creatures recognize the evil that was
driving them and simply wanted to be
away from it the parents need to be
prosecuted and in my never be it so
humble opinion sterilized
it's as simple as that
I don't know if we're ever going to get
legislation through acquiring
sterilization for uh for parents who
bring their kids to drag shows but I
certainly agree with prosecution
this should be this should be a crime
this is uh I mean it already is a crime
and we shouldn't need to stipulate like
there are already crimes Against Child
Abuse child endangerment
um child sexual abuse emotional
psychological abuse I mean all of these
things are already crimes so in fact in
in any state in the Union if you bring
your kid to a drag show you have
violated probably six or seven state
laws already
it's just that those laws don't
stipulate oh by the way this includes
bringing your kid to a drag show
so now that needs to be stipulated I
agree
um
Sean says
Matt as a structural engineer I was
initially offended by your comment that
Engineers are weird but then I
remembered how I got excited about
making a concrete boat nothing wrong
with being weird well depends on like
weird in what way if you're weird like a
a drag performer at an all-ages drag
show that's a bad kind of weird
Engineers are weird though so if you're
an engineer yourself being around a lot
of Engineers I don't think you would
deny that but uh but not maybe weird
eccentric maybe is the word I should
have gone with nothing wrong with being
eccentric
rogo says rogo Rojo Matt at what point
are you just going to bite the bullet
and finally start your own Tick Tock
account
funny story about that we actually did
apparently start a tick tock account for
me uh I think it was about like last
week
so my the social media team started a
tick tock I didn't even know they were
doing it until it was already done and
they started a tick tock account and I
think we made it I'm not saying this is
a record okay I'm not going to claim the
record but it might be close to one we
made it I think five days before we got
uh we got a we had a one week suspension
and Tick Tock never specified what the
reason was was they they said we
violated
their terms of service never never
stipulated what rule we violated exactly
they just suspended us for a weekend so
we'll be we'll be back up and running I
think on Friday until we get banned
permanently
and I'm sure we just got suspended
because Tick Tock looked at it and said
no there's no way we're not letting this
guy on this this is not going to happen
so we'll see we'll see how long we make
it before we get the uh the permanent
ban
the daily wire is hiring a senior
front-end web developer to join our
streaming platform and e-commerce team
you need at least three years of real
world software experience but you do not
need a college degree just big league
coding chops you just got to be able to
do the job who cares about the degree in
Big Bang Theory speak you got to be
Adept in HTML
wait HTML5 css3 JavaScript react native
so two different things are one thing
react
react native is one thing react native
and restful
apis with that are those even things I
don't know I've heard of JavaScript at
least if front-end web development is
your love love language apply to join us
in Nashville where you'll upgrade the
user experience and Beauty not just of
our streaming platform but more
importantly of my specific sections of
the website so go to dailywire.com
careers to apply today also the daily
wire is hiring a senior vice president
of marketing analytics data and
operations I'm told that this is a high
profile executive role with paid
relocation to Nashville this innovator
will Design hire and oversee a
world-class marketing data and analytics
team that is built atop the marketing
data stack from CRM platforms to build
multi-touch attribution tools to
propensity marketing targeting models
why are they giving me a copy like this
anyway if that makes if any of that even
remotely makes sense to you then you
should apply this leader will for
example study which daily wire shows and
films most interest the fans and also
which daily wire host is uh most
annoying because we got to know that too
so if you understand what a full
marketing data and analytics stack is
head over to dailywire.com careers to
apply thank God we sort of got through
that now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well almost exactly five years ago Salon
got on the latinx train in an article
titled forget about Latino why I'm all
for latinx and you should be too writer
Yesenia funes uh hailed the term latinx
as a needed response to the male
dominant Spanish language
now most of us probably hadn't realized
that an entire language needs a response
but Salon realized and they explained
that latinx is a superior word uh
devised by quote feminist and queer
Spanish speakers it is in fact they said
revolutionary because it's inclusive of
those who live outside the gender binary
the article continued quote
that includes people like arigati de
Silva a Venezuelan race and sexuality
educator they are 29 and have used they
them pronouns for a little less than a
decade but they always knew that's how
they felt the Silva just didn't know
genderqueer was a possible identity now
they can add latinx as an identity too I
can understand some hesitance to the
term latings after all X isn't a letter
widely used in the Spanish language so
it might not feel organic rolling off
the tongue de Silva understands that too
but it is what it is
it is what it is how could you argue
with that
case settled especially now the race and
sexuality educator has ruled on the
subject then you know just is what it is
Salon followed orders and they published
many articles in the past five years
which adopted the latinx term articles
with headlines like Hollywood's latinx
representation is dismal why don't
movies look more like America
and also Hollywood is still overlooking
latinx filmmakers
my story matters my pain matters
we're seeing an article published last
month about the the magic of Miami's
modern Daiquiri and it tells us that
Daiquiris are quote a tangible
representation of the relationship
between Cuba latinx culture and Miami
but it seems that sacred bond has now
been broken at least as far as Salon is
concerned
um this article was published by the
outlet yesterday it says stop using
latinx if you really want to be
inclusive
the writer Melissa Ochoa explains that
though when she first heard letings in
2017 she thought it was Progressive and
inclusive she has now realized that
there's a there's a dark underbelly to
this particular form of gibberish
damning it with the harshest term
available to a leftist she has declared
the term problematic
Ochoa explains that first of all nobody
in the actual Latino Community uses the
term you know she says that the term was
invented and is being pushed by
american-born academics mostly the
marginalized communities it's meant to
represent don't like it don't want it
she says that this makes the entire
thing kind of elitist and patronizing
she even points out that latinx erases
sex distinctions and situations where
she would prefer to keep them in place
so for example she says like when you
use the word latinx to describe Hispanic
women in fields where they are quote
underrepresented we're only further
obscuring their contributions
finally she observes that the X affixed
to the word
is not pronounceable in the Spanish
language
and she also wonders how far this will
go
to refer to someone from Mexico or
Argentina do we have to Now call them
mexicanics and argentinx
it's it's a slippery slope she says
this is what Ochoa is arguing
and it sounds exactly like
everything I've been saying about this
issue for the past five years and
everything that all of us on the right
have been saying we have been making all
of these exact arguments ever since we
first heard about this nonsense
but it will not Shock you to learn that
Salon is not going to credit us with
enlightening them on this topic or
winning the argument they're not going
to acknowledge us at all
um no they're going to pretend that they
arrived to this conclusion on their own
and worse
they're going to find a way somehow to
double down even while backing down
this is a move that is uh that is uh you
only find on the left and they're very
good at it to back down while also
doubling down the writer continues many
academics might feel compelled to
continue to use lettings because they
fought hard to have it recognized by
their institutions or they've already
published a term in an academic Journal
but there's a much better gender
inclusive alternative one that's been
largely overlooked by the U.S academic
community and is already being used in
Spanish-speaking parts of Latin America
especially among young social activists
in those countries it's uh Latina
so that's
l-a-t-i-n-e Latina
not Latina Latina
and it's far more adaptable she says to
the Spanish language it could be
implemented as articles less instead of
loss or loss the words for the when it
comes to pronouns L can become a
singular form of they and used in place
of the masculine l or feminine Ella
which translate to he and she it can
also be readily applied to most
nationalities such as Mexicana or
Argentina
I believe Latina Latina accomplishes
what latinx originally meant to and more
similarly it eliminates the gender
binary in its singular and plural form
however Latina is not confined to an
elite English-speaking population within
the U.S it is inclusive
language matters Latina embodies that
inclusivity across socioeconomic status
citizenship education gender identity
age groups and Nations while honoring
the Spanish language in the process
well this is the most you can really
ever expect from the left these days
every once in a while astray like Ochoa
here will wander dangerously close to
the precipice of rationality and then
right before taking the final Plunge
tumble back in the same direction she
came from
indeed all of the very true and valid
criticisms of latinx that she made or
rather we made and then she claimed
credit for are abandoned and ultimately
contradicted by her proposed solution
she is still proposing manipulating a
language to suit the needs and desires
of an academic Elite
she is still advocating something that
nobody in the Latino Community uses or
will use she is still erasing sex
distinctions
so Latina has all of the same problems
of latinx except that it arguably may be
sounds slightly less stupid slightly
she seemed for a moment tempted But
ultimately could not bring herself to
Simply say because this is all that
needs to be said
simply say to the so-called non-binary
people get over yourselves
we aren't going to change an entire
language to suit you
just deal with it your pretentious
egomaniacs
not say that and so she will inevitably
be stuck always catering to the whims of
the most narcissistic and self-involved
people on her side of the ideological
divide
and she will do this even at her own
expense
at the expense of her culture and her
language
what she cannot see
what nobody on the left can see
because if they could see it they'd no
longer be on the left
is that Universal inclusiveness
is not a virtue
it's also not coherent or possible
you you cannot include everything in
anything because if you try you only you
only end up turning the thing into
nothing or else you end up including a
group while excluding another
see the most that inclusion can ever
hope to be
um at least this kind of leftist version
of inclusion is a lateral move it's kind
of a it's a trade-off
you swap one excluded group for another
only the group excluded in the name of
inclusion is usually the group that by
All rights should be the most included
and the group included is the one that
by All rights should not be included at
all so the manipulation of the Spanish
language is the perfect example of this
as it includes these pompous LGBT
obsessed academics while excluding the
everyday average Spanish-speaking people
who've been using this language for
centuries
without a problem
they don't see a problem here this is a
problem created by academic elites on
the left
here's a general rule and this this you
could just like take to the bank okay
if everyone is doing something without
an issue
and then you come along and you're the
only one having a problem
that's probably because you are the
problem
but usually inclusion simply means
destroying that which everyone is being
included in
because when everyone is included in the
definition of the word woman the word
ceases to have all meaning when the
borders are erased and everyone is
included as a citizenship as a citizen
Citizenship ceases to have all meaning
when every shape is included in the word
square squares cease to have all meaning
I am not an advocate for inclusiveness
because I would prefer for everything to
be known and seen for what it is and
treated accordingly
you know not everything can be
everything in fact nothing can be
everything
or else everything will be nothing
now I've kind of confused myself
which I think is sort of the point
and the real point for us is that salon
despite coming precariously close to a
logical viewpoint
still landed A Million Miles Away and
thus is today canceled
and that'll do it for us for this
portion of the show as we move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]